It is fairly common practice
to take this set of data and
fit a line to it using
linear regression.
Let's say we got a line
something like that.
And to look at the statistics
of that linear fit.
One property is the slope.
When we fit a line,
what's the slope of that line?
Let's assume it turns out to be 1 for
this particular stock and
its relationship to the S&P 500.
This slope, in financial terminology,
is usually referred to as beta with
this symbol, or just the word beta.
And what beta means is how reactive
is the stock to the market.
So if beta is 1, and
we have a slope here of 1, it means,
on average, when the market goes up 1%,
that particular stock also goes up 1%.
If we have, say, a higher number, say,
2, that would mean that if
the market were to go up 1%,
we'd expect on average for
that stock to go up 2%.
There's another factor you can see here
when you look at where that line
intercepts the vertical axis.
That is called alpha.
And you've probably heard about
alpha in investing circles, and
what that means is that this stock is
actually on average performing a little
bit better than the S&P 500 every day
if that number, alpha, is positive.
If it's negative,
it means on average it's returning a
little bit less than the market overall.
That's how you can plot the data,
fit a line to it, and
measure a couple aspects of this
performance with regard to the market or
with regard to some other stock.